mais avant ça je voudrais revenir aux
événements tragiques du début de l'après
midi à new york et écouter de nouveau
des témoignages de new yorkais qui se
sont trouvées prises au piège tout au
long de cet après midi on les écoute
faire avec les moyens du bord
ils étaient les premiers sur place
la fumée a rendu leurs efforts
impossible terrassé ses pompiers tentent
de se reposer un peu avant de repartir
leur seul espoir que la fumée
disparaissent pour les laisser enfin
travailler
c'est fou j'étais au troisième étage
dans l'immeuble d'en face où nous
travaillons et nous avons vu le second
appareil s'encastrer dans le workflow
aussitôt le building s'est effondré le
world trade center s'est effondré au
beau milieu du quartier financier de new
york
une seule interrogation combien de
personnes étaient à l'intérieur
plus de dix mille personnes travaillent
dans chacune de ces de tous il ya aussi
de sa vie de visiteurs par jour alors à
l'heure de l'explosion à 9h30 du matin
et deux images étaient pleins la panique
a aussitôt gagné le coeur de manhattan
tous les habitants cherchent à tout prix
à fuir nous faisons une recherche étage
par étage
la police de new york tente de savoir
qui était présent à l'intérieur au
moment de l'explosion mais comme vous le
savez il ya encore beaucoup de personnes
à se courir à la maison blanche
une consigne évacuation générale
washington ne veut prendre aucun risque